welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one of
mission episode eight a trip through
history that
probably broke your heart somehow i'm
here for you we're gonna go back through
this episode frame by
frame for all the visual details you
missed the latin you need translated
and the increasingly hopeless fan
theories that you need evidence to
justify
here we go episode titled previously on
so we gotta start in the previously on
segment the audio mix
boosts the violent hits of wanda's past
the
blocks thanos backhand the prying of the
stone from vision's head
[Music]
just a reminder that wanda's past has
been brutal
she has suffered so much but all this
suffering is so that she can learn a key
lesson about grief that it is actually
love
persevering you'll notice the marvel
title card fades to purple the color of
agatha harkness as we open on this salem
witch trial
sort of like agatha's in the comics but
here trial by witches
when your own coven doesn't want you you
know you [ __ ] up leading this covenant
is agatha's mother
evanora harkness wearing the brooch its
three figures resemble the three graces
of greek mythology though given this is
a coven
it could reflect the three witches of
macbeth or the three
fates of greek mythology which does
connect with aguila plucking
wanda's hair to represent wanda's
lifeline evanor accuses her daughter
you have betrayed your coven stole
knowledge
above your age and station i did not
break
your rules they simply bent to my power
this is similar to steven strange who
learned sorcery too
quickly and fast-tracked himself to
sorcerer supreme by reading forbidden
texts on magic from the dark dimension
in agatha's case her forbidden textbook
was the darkhold
a book many of us believe is actually
from the camertaj library with its
hexagonal slots though that open slot
visible in the doctor strange movie was
not for the darkhold it was the book of
cagliostro which was just not there in
that shot and the witch's chant
in latin
i cannot control it roughly translating
to death to the monster of nature so
this means they view her as a freak of
nature that needs to be put down
a natural threat that is beyond which
cultural norms it's also notable that
their spells are in latin
most spells found in real world tomes
are in that language
and i see this as tying the imsu's
witchcraft to
christian medieval history which means
all that fire and brimstone of christian
dogma could come with it
agatha's purple magic bursts out of her
seemingly without her control
as if an independent sentence is
protecting her
and so she's able to drain the life
force from the others and notice how
that magic rests in her palms
in a mix of purple and blue suggesting
she has the power of
all nine and these also become the two
colors that are reflected in her purple
and blue wardrobe at the end of the
episode evanor's blue magic forms this
crown around her head
one that agatha does not gain when she
drains her mother
though in wanda's vision of her future
as a scarlet witch her tierra does
appear
on her head this might tell us what
agatha wants from wanda
the crown that is worn by the dominant
witch
and this whole royal dispute is
backdropped by these waterfalls which do
kind of parallel the wakandan warrior
falls where royals do
fight for that throne which
interestingly is also passed along via a
kind of purple colored sorcery and agave
leaves us in a trail of purple magic
that dissolves into the
rabbit
no i know she does look shocked to meet
the realest so
last week i wondered if senor scratchy
could be nicholas scratch agatha sun
transmuted into pietro but after this i
am now back to my first instinct that
this rabbit could be agatha's husband
ralph
we know this rabbit is important folks
agave says the real
us she feeds him an insect which he
gobbles up despite rabbits being
herbivores
he sits right beside the open dark hole
and notice how wanda cannot look away
from this rabbit in this moment
i need you hey
but i got more on this rabbit and ralph
later she points out these runes that
are protection spells
one has this m shape which you could see
agatha's house here as
a house of m within the house of m
inspired story that this is
and she explains fake pietro or fiatro
that was you no it wasn't literally me
just my
eyes and ears a christalum possession
necromancy was a non-starter since your
real brother's body is on another
continent
so earlier this week kevin feige said
evan peter's casting was to use his
words
just another way that certain people
were messing around with wanda
yeah i'm sure the fox quick silver fans
will accept that it's also interesting
how feige said
certain people another hint that agatha
might not be working alone
agatha also confirms that she did not
create the hex but just rather crashed
the party that wanda started he sensed
this place so many spells
cast all at once i couldn't make heads
or tails of it
which begs the question if she could
sense the hex shouldn't
also the sorcerer's supreme doctor
strange be able to sense it i
assume he could be on his way and she
controls the cicada
pineal impediment
in latin roughly i have control of the
animal
look latin heads i know it doesn't match
up it's hard to hear exactly what
they're saying and they don't give
subtitles and then she transmutes the
skater into a
bird
which roughly in latin transform your
appearance and then she uses wanda's
hair
to project her back into her memories
which literally i think is just remember
memory and remember doctor strange
similarly plucked one of thor's hairs
out of his head to locate odin back into
a ragnarok but here the hair
extends into this lifeline bisecting
this door with nine
circles which might reflect those nine
members of the coven agatha evanora and
the seven others
they could also reflect the nine circles
of hell in dante's inferno in which
dante and virgil traverse
and observe each ring of hell the
bottommost layer
is frozen like sokovia is but listen to
the music as they enter this apartment
[Music]
yeah those cello notes sounds a lot like
the tragic porch theme from the end of
infinity war
moments after wanda lost vision and
dusted into the void
so we find out what the sitcoms are all
about maxima family love to watch sitcom
dvds instead of oh i don't know fleeing
the
country so what do we got here i love
lucy bewitched adam's family who's the
boss i dream of genie malcolm in the
middle
well this was in 1999 michael in the
middle season one didn't come out on dvd
until 2002. oh shut up this is sweet
and notice what her mom does don't look
that is the sokovian greeting that wanda
envisioned brought up jokingly in
episode one
that this is the traditional sokovian
greeting of hospitality uh guess who
oh is that my host behind me it
certainly is
sweet so wanda singles out her favorite
tv episode as the dick van dyke show
season 2
episode 21 it may look like a walnut now
technically that's the 20th episode to
air that season but the dvd said
reorders it to number 21 but this isn't
just any episode folks
in this episode rob watches a scary
sci-fi tv program about
aliens and glowing walnuts about people
losing their thumbs
because the aliens don't want humans to
be able to make technology that can
threaten them
and then he wakes up in a twilight zone
scenario in which this seems to have
come
true this is exactly what westview is
for wanda it is a classic sitcom that
also has elements of the twilight zone
that seems to be weirdly obsessed with
flying saucers and aliens and with
hayward seems to be connected to a plot
about playing god with tech at a
paranoia of alien threats and meanwhile
their descriptions of this genre match
the genre-bending aspect of wandavision
itself
along with where this show might be
going again
is like problem but more silly than
scary but
can sometimes be a little scary a silly
mischief that
always becomes fine by the end of the
episode you realize it was all a bad
dream
but then boom you're looking for this
the home gets bombed and then we see
that stark industries bombshell feet
away the story they told in age of
ultron and of course it beeps
the same sound effect and blinking red
light as that stark toaster in the
commercial
but interestingly this bomb failed to
detonate not by chance but rather wanda
using a probability hex
one of wanda's chaos magic powers in the
comics and a major detail confirming
that wanda's powers did not come fully
from the mind stone but
existed in a lower powered form from
birth meaning this is in her dna
she's got a mutant gene folks but then
notice behind the bomb dick van dyke
says
on the tv and i am legally obligated to
point out every mention of the word
nightmare just because nightmare ends up
being in this
then to the hydra lab where wanda tells
agatha we wanted to change the world
it started as a political ideal but
wanda is now capable of doing this
literally and then i
love this transition the camera pulls
back into the chamber but uh just
kidding we're actually seeing a mirror
surface but no
camera reflected in that mirror i keep
mentioning references to contact in
these breakdowns but
this impossible mirror shot is also a
famous maneuver from that movie it's one
of my favorite shots
ever in movies and in that scene that
was a flashback to a childhood trauma
just like this is for wanda now this
mind stone oddly seems to select wanda
it washes yellow radiation over her
and her eyes reflect the silhouette of
her future form
or maybe an alternate reality form
either way
a true nexus being the scarlet witch
this actually could be the figure we saw
briefly in wanda's eyes at the end of
episode six
the moment she expanded and for the
first time threatened this universe with
a house of m style rewrite and then when
they tried to play back the video it
glitches from right before to right
after
just like the editing glitches later in
westview also i'm sorry to keep doing
this
but this also happens in the movie
contact when external video skips over
ellie's trans-dimensional trip
seriously is that damn cameo gonna be
jody foster wanda watches an episode of
the brady bunch with
cindy brady's doll this is the same doll
vision practice diaper changing on in
episode three
and then on to the avengers compound
again listen to the music
oh wanda moving on up
[Music]
so where are we now the avengers
compound
yeah that music is a dark version of the
classic avengers theme this is set
around the time of civil war when she
was under lockdown and getting to know
vision making some pepper cash together
she watches an episode of malcolm in the
middle where the roof collapses on brian
cranston maybe reflecting how wanda's
hex begins to collapse as the decades
progress
into that era and then vision gives us
the amazing line
really the reason these two weirdos are
able to fall in love but what is grief
if not love persevering
an agatha wife's a tear now this might
be more sarcasm
but wanda isn't looking at her i think i
connected to that
she is so desperate come on wanda you're
on the precipice
you're right there tell me how you did
it
vision was gone but you
wanted him back i wanted it back
and notice agatha's face as wanda leaves
this witch is going through
something i believe agatha lost someone
she loved
and that is why she was so genuinely
emotional when she heard wanda could
raise the dead
you can do that you know i've been
looking and listening at these
characters for a while but do you ever
wonder what they smell
like i'm super self-conscious about
smelling because i used a weird soap for
a while
the brands of big soap that you're
probably using daily are packed with
harmful chemicals and most of them smell
like it too
plastic figurines are fun to collect but
i'm not out here trying to smell like
one well
dr squatch is changing the hygiene game
with their natural healthy products that
make you feel like a man and smell like
a champion they got all kinds of great
scents
a grapefruit ipa deep sea goat's milk
pine tar other ones like cedar citrus
bay rum
all of dr squatch's soaps are made in
the usa using the finest ingredients
nature has to offer look on the label
and you'll recognize everything in there
hundreds of thousands of men
already subscribed to dr squatch meaning
every month fresh bars of squats show up
at their door if you use dr squatch and
you can honestly say it's not the best
bar of soap you've ever used they will
send you your money back no questions
asked i switched to dr squatch like a
week ago i've been sharing with it for
the past week and it has brought a
little bit of joy to my routine it
leaves my skin feeling refreshed and
smelling like a clean man
and not like a funko pop new customers
can get 20
off on orders of 20 or more when you use
the promo code
dsc new rockstars20 click on the link in
the description below again that's 20
off on orders of 20 or more check it out
with the link in the video's description
so at sword hq wanda looks in at hayward
through the monitor just like she did
via the drone camera in episode five
behind the desk is a star map front and
center is gemini
the twins like guana pietro billy and
tommy and notice how hayward calls
vision
the vision which is also how it's listed
on the deed nice to see the mcu use the
the like in the comics and then hayward
shows wanda visions
parts bit hard to watch the wiring pulls
apart with a slick
sound as if it was sinew and muscle
tissue
and then under that skin wouldn't you
know it looks like some hexagonal tissue
there
so why did hayward wait to dismantle
vision until now if vision has been dead
for years
did he fear that the returned avengers
would try to seize the parts
did wakanda not release the body until
shuri and t'challa blipped back well
take a step back and look at this scene
the sword texts are sloppy
yanking vision apart like an old car he
is a three billion dollar sentient
weapon and this looks like tim the tool
man taylor's garage
and then hayward basically shows his
carts are you sure excuse me
not everyone has the kind of power that
could bring their soulmate back online
forgive me back to life and throughout
this he is watching wanda closely with a
bit of hopefulness and he tells his men
to stand down yeah clearly this is
all a show by hayward he once wanted to
take this corpse
over the past years he has been trying
to reboot vision thousands of times
to no avail and now that wanna
maximoff's back he
is butchering vision trying to incite
wanda into snatching the body
and using her sorcery hayward hopes to
bring this back online
and when wanda leaves without visions
corpse he's disappointed he lies to
monica saying that wanda did
while throwing monica at west view
hoping for a sample of wanda's magic
which
he gets eventually with that stark drone
getting the fuel for his project
cataract to reboot vision
giving us white vision in the
post-credits scene now white vision is
from the vision quest comics and the
west coast avengers series in the 80s
where the avengers are trying to
reassemble vision's body
the visuals of him on the different
tables actually look very similar but
because vision does not have the same
brain waves that he used to have he
comes back
in this soulless white form in the
comics there's a lot of other characters
involved with this
from the grim reaper to wonder man to
hank pym to even the human torch
and technically immortus who is the same
person as kang the conqueror
seems like one division might not bring
in any of them hayward is really just a
government villain who wants superheroes
he can control as weapons
and the fact that white vision has a
stark-esque arc
reactor in his forehead where the mind
stone would be echoes the way tony stark
tried to do this which led to the folly
of ultron
and the saving grace of the true vision
this plan is why hayward here ultimately
just puts a price tag on vision i cannot
allow you to take three billion dollars
worth of vibranium just to put it in the
ground
but if you think about it that is
exactly where the vibranium belongs the
vibranium that made vision
was stolen from the soil of wakanda
meanwhile wanda's plan it seems like was
to try to bury vision
in that plot he bought for them in west
view new jersey would you think about it
when did he get that deed he must have
done it before they went on the run
after civil war in 2016.
he is essentially a guy who got an
engagement ring after the first date
in other words a creep and then wanda
says here i can't
feel you which of course is a callback
to infinity war when wanda used her
magic in the earlier scene to sense
vision's soul from that mind stone
and these were also his final words to
her before she destroyed that stone at
the end of the movie and heading to west
view wanda drives a red car
it's got a license plate reading
excelsior which of course is just the
new york state motto it's on all these
plates but also it is stan lee's
catchphrase
we see john collins aka herb sharon
davis aka mrs hart dennis the mailman
aka pizza time pizza time harold proctor
gage jones he puts up an ad for piano
lessons remember he played it at the
talent show
until it was flattened that was my
grandmother's piano
and on the deed vision's note is
outlined in a heart like the date on the
calendar in episode 1 the heart they
could not remember the meaning of and
his address 2800 sure would could be an
idea sherwood schwartz the producer of
the brady bunch and a bunch of other
sitcoms and it is signed off by the name
kate weddle who is an assistant art
director on one division and
in her grief wanda uses her sorcery to
construct this dream home
the house builds in jigsaw chunks
interestingly evoking the puzzle pieces
of joe quesada's house of m cover and
this hex spreads like a wave
a reversal of wanda's admission earlier
to feeling like
she was caught in the wave getting
toppled over and over now
she is a seismic event that spreads the
weight outward the westview dairy
billboard reverts from the red carton
modern one to the old timey bottles just
like wanda's glitching milk last episode
and then over on the right a new ad for
lagos paper towels make cleaning up a
snap
like you know the snap that thanos did
the movie theater marquee changes from
ten house or gate a nod to blade runner
that was the warp station referenced in
the amazing tears of rain monologue
now it reads big red and kidnapped the
way these town residents are essentially
kidnapped in a big red hex and inside
the house wanda recreates vision solely
out of
yellow magic due to her magic being
amplified by the yellow mind stone
and in the tv reflection you can see
vision's mind stone is the last part of
him to form
this means that the vision in west view
is resurrected purely from wanda's magic
and has no corporeal counterpart yet he
is still real
inside the hex because remember hayward
was able to track his vibranium decay
all this means that as a nexus being
wanda isn't just creating illusions
she's creating
real tangible alternate realities and
then in the tv studio behind the stage
lights is the year 2013
which does anchor this final modern
family sitcom year as the year 2013 even
though on the outside world it is
2023 and then outside final scene agatha
restrains billy and tommy on these
choke leashes you have no idea
how dangerous you are you're supposed to
be a myth
of being capable of spontaneous creation
here you are using it to make breakfast
for dinner which calls back wanda
failing at agnes recipes in episode one
and just
improvising breakfast for dinner but now
looking back on it those complex recipes
provided by agnes might have actually
been
spells from the darkhold that agatha was
using to test wanda this is why agatha's
so frustrated
that rather than following the basics
like she had to wanda could just skip
that textbook and agava ends with
this is chaos magic wanda and that makes
you
the scarlet witch this is the first for
two terms in the mcu
chaos magic which is of course the type
of magic wanda uses in the comics the
reason she can chaotically rewrite the
universe as a nexus bean and then of
course her basic superhero name scarlet
witch never been said before in the mcu
and now it's in this interesting context
as being elevated as a kind of royal
title that agatha seeks
but why does agatha want it what is
agatha want
well again akavith seems to have lost
someone she loves and she's frustrated
that she can only do basic spells like
animal transmutation while wanda just
has this innate
power that she didn't really earn and
who would agatha love
well as a witch of salem folks read up
on your history it's not reaching to
assume
this witch would claim her spouse to be
the devil
yeah folks i'm going down with the ship
right or wrong because it's the best
evidence we got here's my closing
argument
agatha's husband ralph is mephisto aka
senor scratchy the rabbit a reference to
old scratch a nickname for the devil
this rabbit is the best agatha could do
to bring him back
using spells from the darkhold this is a
rabbit remember she bragged as having
star potential senor scratch he's got
real star quality don't you think
it was his demonic protection that
allowed agatha to overthrow the coven
but
doing that broke his soul because agatha
was not the scarlet witch that he
thought she was she did not get the
crown and as in the west coast avengers
comics this series is now
definitely based on evidenced by white
vision mephisto's soul is broken in
those comics
agatha helps him manipulate wanda using
pieces of his soul
to create billy and tommy later shown to
be hand puppets of
mephisto's minion and now agatha puppets
these boys like marionettes on strings
and notice as she does this her fingers
turn black
suggesting that these illusions are
actually draining some of her life force
these kids were just called demon spawn
and that was not long after the devil's
in the details bev
that's not the only place he is what
does zagato want she wants the nexus
powers of the scarlet witch
she was unable to get them from her
mother and she wants them now from wanda
so that she can repair mephisto's soul
and together
they can rule the multiverse a power
that the rest of her coven thought no
one
should harness i know i know it seems
like the betany cameo tease might have
been just him trolling us but uh
i am gonna place my bets on mephisto
showing up in the finale he's gonna be
played by an actor so beloved no one's
gonna care that he's been off screen all
season or how weird it is that the mcu
has satan in it now
and no china censorship does not
actually apply here we did a whole video
on why check it out so mephisto you are
clear for
landing we are so close and don't you
dare pull a db cooper on us
hey you can support this channel by
checking out one of our wonderful merch
options at newrockersmirch.com like this
unusual couple shirt and if you want to
win a free ps5
our merch partners over at epic hero
labs are doing a giveaway
just subscribe to the channel epic hero
labs and then head on over to
epicheroshop.com
giveaway for more ways to enter every
ten thousand subscribers are going to
give away a new ps5 and they're so close
to that next one you could be the lucky
winner
and of course follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
for all your one division questions
thank you for watching and
don't stop believing
hold on
[Music]
spirano's got to black
[Music]
you